and uh to our audience uh get ready
because this is it uh for first place
all the marbles and so many points of
the GCT somebody's walking away with 13
GCT points and ne's looking across and
he's going like man that should be me
and he was so close as well yes I should
be playing for first he would have been
on this table he would have been the one
fighting it out and he knows it it can't
be a happy round for him and it's go
time and has played it is one D4 Peter
youo no grun
field Queen Gambit declined so we got to
play Bishop G5 and not allow a Queen's
Gambit accepted
no that's interesting I think that
allows options it does allow D5 take C4
followed by B5 right and the same love I
like the same is slav as a choice keeps
pieces on the board very difficult to
completely vacuum things off the board
in in the semis slav positions are very
dry we're not going to see a Morano
though we're going to see a bishop D6
Bishop D3 is actually a very good choice
in this spot because right you're
forcing either black to not equalize or
to enter some very forcing variations
with and how much of the Morano
variations does mvl know somebody's
bluffing somebody I just don't know who
who's the better bluffer here Peter and
and in the Mirano you absolutely play A6
on after the B let's say if the bishop
goes to D3 here you don't play Bishop B7
which probably equalizes but no no more
B E2 also a line also a line of play but
you're saying A7 A6 and then you go for
the quick C5 business yeah you you have
to play for those positions because you
don't go for the B4 Bishop B7 no those
are very very dry yeah um against Bishop
B2 I think A6 is supposed not to be any
good I'm trying to remember the exact it
might be E4 B4 E5 which becomes and E4
C5 is also not that great for some I
guess yeah this is the point the
difference is if you put if while he's
thinking A6 yes E4 ah he has not done E4
I'm I'm I'm a bit surprised because this
A6 E4 B4 you were about to say E5 yeah
E5 is good there and after C5 uh the
fact that we can take Queen takes D4 in
some positions compared to the positions
with Bishop on D3 is massively important
and we do have C6 C5 on the board mhm D4
D5 he's played it it keeps uh we take
and go Bishop B7 I don't think we are
unhappy about this well you take you go
Bishop B7 we play E4 I assume I take on
D5 I play Bishop D6 I think Fab will
take one F6 and play A4 I think he'll go
into end games those end games could be
a hang on maybe we take with the queen
considering the tournament situation
Bishop B7 by the way on but I'm voting
Knight takes F6 here I'm I'm not voting
for E4 Knight takes F6 Queen takes F6
and throw an A4 throw an A4 somewhere
yes very nicely put T that A2 A4 comes
perfectly Tim you you you hit the B5
Pawn you get to trade a pair of Rooks
maybe and he's done it Knight takes F6 I
think ail has to take with W he takes
with the Knight so Queen trades on offer
but now we definitely take take play we
play A4 I think this will be very
difficult to or even the
immediately this actually shocks me a
little bit because I think it just makes
makes white so easier totally is there a
wave to avoid Queen J because you can go
Queen B6 but then you anyway take and go
Queen take the rook and then go Queen B3
at the end of it even que3 right away
you put your queen on B6 Queen B3 right
away C4 Bishop C4 oo B4 uhoh uhoh uh C4
is a juicy Square it certainly is I mean
I would be making a beline to that
square Knight E5 Bishop F3 Knight C4
even Bishop C4 here looks very good B3
Bishop B2 looks very good I I have a
feeling white is just much better now
much better yeah the one thing you have
to watch out for is if you play B3 you
have you have to be very certain the
knight from F6 doesn't just land on C3
very quickly right that's the one source
of counter play you need to be
constantly on the lookout for but uh it
looks like a very good uh play by fabbi
he's got his Bishop on B2 and
everything's still looking very nice I I
I'm anxious to play Knight C4 Tanya but
the one good thing for maxim is that the
Queens are still on the board needing a
win I think there was an opportunity for
white to trade and go for the exact idea
that you pointing out with your arrows
but with the Queens on the board and the
two Bishops lined up towards White's
King side uh sure you get your knight to
C4 and it's all of us would pick white
here but there is still a lot of game to
be played Queen E7 Rook d8 Rook
E8 and we or queen C7 as you're pointing
out
three
uh showing a
remarkable uh composure in not jumping
to the C4 Square
H3 is jumping in with a night do what
that C3 Square because uh as Peter Peter
mentioned the one thing that you have to
be mindful of is a night landing on the
C3 Square when you're not ready for it
by the way Queen C2 Queen D7 just as
you'd like Rook
D1 bring the Rook to d8 everybody's
happy you want to play N9 G2 here with
white but you might be blundering n
G3 ooh so very careful now Knight D2
Knight G3 with the idea F takes Queen
takes E3 check and I'm in your business
as we say yes yes because Rook F2 runs
into Bishop takes Pawn on G3 and your
Rook on F2 Pinn exactly no Knight d2s
and suddenly okay I'm not saying it's
completely ridiculous but don't forget
the tournament situation mvl has to win
and he's Bishop C4 is correct I think
he's setting the stage yeah it really
feels like that in a must situation with
black this is the outcome that you want
out of the opening truly truly now I'm
not threatening Bishop D5 because there
is a bishop H2 discovery
yeah Knight C3 is Knight G5 interesting
takes takes on A4 though I think this
makes F's life much easier uh I was
thinking ny3 yeah but it's probably not
more than a Perpetual I think the reason
he hasn't done it is that we can
actually accept the sacrifice and you
have theet but you don't you don't have
anything more okay uh Peter you said
this makes Whit's life easier why well
we've completely protected the G2 Pawn
our Bishops now are actually better than
Black's Bishop the bishop on D6 is
completely cut off from the game we can
even maybe launch some of our own play
like Queen of2 G3 here is a very
legitimate source of que G4 as well yeah
our pawns are a bit more mobile while
this Pawn on C5 is nicely blockaded I
feel I feel like like Bobby controlling
this nicely is is doing really well
Suddenly It's really that move Knight G5
kind of spoiled Black's attack yeah just
one Trader pieces and how much it
changes the position it's completely
taken away
the chances that Maxim had because
notice how now it's White's Bishop the
one and B2 and C4 which look so much
more powerful agreed the pawns can start
moving forward when the time is right
but first it's about peace activity and
I'm liking white now it would have been
very different a few moves ago I I have
a feeling might be winning but you never
played in a in's tournament situation
you just never wasn't there the ghost of
Ray Robson with F5 and F6 didn't
somebody do the F5 Bishop E5 F6 was very
playable yeah uh and sacrificer yes yes
that would have been fun but and uh
White is the one enjoying the
proceedings we have King h8 yes and now
the E3 Pawn is got it so the queen can
uh jump over to
G4 prepared F6 now I was wondering if we
were eyeballing the A6 Pawn but then you
lose something in the center probably
you lose no with the Rook on E1 I was
going to take on d8 then Bishop takes A4
in the end oh and also Rook D1 and E3
was hanging in lines he goes Queen G4
thread of Maiden one F6 that's a very
professional decision there by Fabby
gets SNS off the
board that's he only a draw by the way
that's Checkmate to the queen absolutely
there's that black queen is not escaping
there is a forced trade okay but mvl
says let's play on let's March Soldier
on I've got Bishop C2 on my agenda what
are you going to do about it Bishop C4
A5 King F we're not getting distracted
from this but uh the game between Yan
pishi and Anish giri ended in a draw
meaning
that uh MBL cannot lose the second place
at least yes and also meaning that
perhaps the players are more interested
in this game than any other game than
the one they're playing themselves it is
the championship game Let's remind
everyone and Fabiano Carana needs only a
draw to clinch clear first to clinch
clear first and and 13 GCT points
additional 13 GCT points being already
the leader of the Tour by the way the
last move King
G2 just to take away some of White's
flexibility I might be inclined to play
Bishop G2 here trying to provoke the
move H4 so I don't get
uh I don't have to deal with G4 but okay
he's played King to uh
G6 playing for King F5 by the way I
think it's really really really
Justified that mvl get at least a clear
second because he's played such a very
impressive Blitz event that some
sometimes you lose the last round game
and you you drop to I think if he loses
he will ti ti for second but Tye for
second I think so I think he's only half
a point ahead of of yan so okay and no
question of that both these players
whoever wins it is the mo is is a
deserving winner they've played
fantastic chess in the blitz just
amazing amazing games this end game well
the Bishops have been traded off who are
we picking here is is it completely in
Balance no I still like white because
this Pawn on C5 is not it's it's not
brilliant right whereas this Pawn on e4
like I'm not sure King F5 now I don't
think you can play King F3 because Rook
D3 is extremely strong H Rook C1 may be
strong though could consider throwing in
C5 C4 here just to create the passer but
it's a h yeah guess what Peter and he
does that yeah nicely
spotted so the idea it's a positional
sacrifice the idea is to put the King on
inst instantly returned it
wow okay both both the memberships into
the pong grubber Club has been cancelled
revoked revoked denied license revoked
Rook C1 instructive right that pawn is
more useful to White off the boat than
on it because you want some more peace
activity I may be flipping I may be
flipping uh suddenly the queenside pawns
have become meaningful B3 but then I I
thought there was a good Rook C3 Rook B8
though B3 is a very B Rook D2 is your
idea correct absolutely that would
that's on my C3 you'll have to play Rook
B8 but Rook B8 is perfectly serviceable
and now Rook C4 the bishop endings are
completely equal after Rook B4 that's
not a winning attempt so it's very
unclear how how is black Rook getting
into the game here back to Rook to d8 to
D2 that's that's my only inroad that's
the threat now Rook d8 coming in he's
taking away the C3 Square
first very nicely done by mvl spotting
the the geometry there is the that
there's uh he would like to play Bishop
C3 here but that loses maybe to Rook H
do he want to go Rook to B1 and start
targeting the B3 Pawn if Rook H2 Rook B1
and then you move the bishop King C4
hold on very clever by five are you sure
Rook
h21 Rook
G2 yeah just Bishop D4 and take on B3
and we should be okay
are it's still Level material it's still
Level material but I'll have a pass G
Pawn eventually you'll have to spend
some time developing it by that point
I'll play Bishop C3 trade the Bishops
off and and when you do white will have
a pass the Eon as well it's so far away
that we're looking at maybe 10 against
25 by the way very very second has
always been such a marvelous Blitzer I
mean he somehow he He Man manages to
keep ahead 10 30 seconds is is for PA I
think just got up he's going to give up
the A4 Pawn is he making a draw here not
convincing yeah is is the one with the
best chances suddenly and maybe he had
to go with his King to C4 to grab B3 so
A4 could have been defended but he even
reached for it and then somehow thought
thought better of it yeah thought better
of it for some reason Rook F3 Rook F3 do
very strong attacking the F PA forcing
white to put pieces on King E6 no do you
go E5 and try and create play he doesn't
want to do that once because it also
gives black an additional G hold on
what's going on you've got a passer on
the G passer who who whoa whoa what what
just
Happ oh he missed it he missed an
opportunity for Rook A3 was that just a
pin on you win the yes the bishop you
you oh you win exchange that would have
been e is in trouble he has to play5
this is no longer a
draw four against n by the way oh no
this will be decided on on on oh did he
who oh my
God he played rookie two and lost The
Rook oh this is a drao yes Fab will be
oh my goodness and Fabiano Carana is the
winner of the St Louis rapid and Blitz
Dr drama to the last Dr congratulations
to Fabby but yeah that was quite
something do we still have one game
remaining let's just check in on Sam
versus Wesley I don't see a result we
see Maxim lra congratulating Fabby for
his performance there what a game what a
finish